(house band instrumentals)
- All right, welcome back everybody.
Two years ago, my next guest used TikTok
to land a book deal.
Since then, she released "Lightlark,"
which became a bestselling,
and soon to be movie.
Now she's back with the sequel,
it's called "Nightbane,"
and it's one of the most
anticipated young adult novels
of the year.
Please welcome back to
the show, Alex Aster.
(audience cheers)
(instrumental jazz)
I'm so glad. I love having you back.
- Thank you.
- This is so exciting.
- I'm so excited.
- Your life just keeps
getting better and better.
- It's changed since the
last time I was here.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Honestly, thanks to your show a lot too,
so, thank you for having me.
- Oh, no, it's thanks to you.
Girl, look at you're writing.
I love this, so I have to ask.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- This my favorite thing I learned.
So, you name your villains and your books
off of people you don't like?
- So I.
- You should have been a
songwriter, I'm just saying.
- So, Kelly, I follow the
Taylor Swift rule of writing.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- If you do not want a song,
or a book, written about you,
don't be mean. Don't be
mean to writers. (laughs)
- Yeah, that'd your fault. That's on you.
(audience cheers)
- Yeah, in reality, I always need names.
Like, when you're writing a book.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Sometimes you use a filler name.
And so, I just, kind of, thought one day,
"Hmm, I need a, a name for the villain."
And, I was like, "I don't
really like that person.
Maybe, they would be the good
person to like fit in there."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They don't usually end
up in the final copy.
One, because I don't wanna be sued.
And. (laughs)
- You are smart, as well.
- And, two, because their names
are never that interesting.
Like, I write fantasy, so
you can't have, like, a Chad
be the villain of like a fantasy book.
- Because Chad wears a
puca shell necklace. Yeah.
- (laughs) Yeah.
It's not, like, competing
in a deadly games, so, yeah.
So, I usually do change it,
but it's a habit that I've developed,
and I post a lot about it.
And so, the funny part is
that thousands of people
will comment on my posts
with name suggestions.
- Oh my God. They're like, "please!"
- Yes, "please!" Like, "Julie,"
or, like, they'll just name.
So, I have a whole list of names.
I don't even need to think about people
in my own life anymore.
- That's very helpful.
- Yes.
- Well, catch us up
on the series. What's going on right now?
- So, for anyone that isn't familiar,
"Lightlark" is about
an island that appears.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Once every hundred years
to host a game where six rulers fight
to break their deadly curses.
So, to break them all, one
of the six rulers has to die
and one will win unmatched power.
So, there's adventure,
romance, big plot twist.
You don't know who's lying
until the very last page,
and "Nightbane," the next
book, which is out now,
starts exactly where "Lightlark" ends.
So, you can almost read
it like a giant book.
- Yes!
- And, like the last
time I was here, I said
it's being made into a
movie franchise by Universal
and the people behind a
very big young adult series
that you might know.
- That's amazing.
- [Alex] Yeah!
- I'm so excited for you.
- Yeah, I'm so excited too.
I was here exactly a year ago,
and it was just the
beginning of "Lightlark,"
and now "Nightbane," is coming out,
so it's really a full circle moment.
- Oh my God.
(audience claps)
Wait, so what was your
like favorite genre,
like, growing up, what was
your favorite book genre?
- My favorite book genre growing up
was the genre I'm writing
in now, young adult fantasy.
- [Alex] That makes sense.
- So, my favorite book was
"Twilight," growing Up.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- That was the first
book that I ever read,
that I was like, "wow,
reading can be really fun."
And so, I set out to write books
that could really be escapist,
and like, get people out
of their normal world.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, that's what I write now.
- Get people interested
in reading, as well.
- [Alex] Yes, exactly!
- 'Cause a lot of people
like the young adult fantasy,
that kind of thing.
So, yeah.
- Yes. Adults read it too.
- Yeah.
- Like, most of the.
- Oh, I read all that too, yeah.
- [Alex] Yeah. (giggles)
- My mother and I are big into that.
We always.
- [Alex] I love that.
- I love a series.
- [Alex] Yes!
- I hate When it's one
book, I'm like. (groans)
- Now you can read both books.
- [Kelly] I know.
- And, like, just combine them both, yeah.
- I love that. I love a series.
So, I heard that you also said
Gen-Zers are, like,
different types of readers.
- Yes.
- What do you mean?
- I think that people think
that now with social media,
people's attention spans,
and like kids aren't reading.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, now in the last few years,
it's honestly the opposite.
And, it's kind of funny,
because social media is
getting people reading.
So, my books were
discovered on social media
and so many more millions of
books are being discovered,
and these people now are becoming readers.
Like you said,
you just need one book
to get you into reading.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, then you're a lifelong reader.
- So, people are discovering
my books on social media
and they're becoming readers.
So, it's really interesting
how social media now
is making people read.
Whereas, I think the public perception
is that Gen Z isn't reading,
but they're reading now
more than ever, book sales are up.
So it's great.
- Yeah.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- It is interesting
too for any generation.
I just think it has to be
something you're interested in.
- [Alex] Yes.
- Right?
Because my sister, even we
were talking about this today,
and, you know, we're both over 40.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- And, she was like, "You know,
I never really liked reading
until you showed me," and I
don't know if it was Jane Austen
or Jane Eyre or something that
was as an author of the book.
- Yeah.
- But, I don't know which one it was,
but she was like, "It really got me in."
- [Alex] Yes.
- And then, that thing opened up.
Now, she reads more books
than I'll ever eat in my entire life.
- You just need that one book.
- I'm like, "how do you have
the time?" I'm like, yeah.
- I know, and so, I was
honestly writing the books
that I wanted to read.
And so that's like how I started.
- That's the best thing to do.
- Yeah.
That's like how I wanna make shows.
They're like, "You should do a show".
And, I'm like, "but I wanna
make one I wanna watch."
- Yes.
I think that when it
starts from that place,
it can always be good because
there's people like you
who would wanna read it or watch it.
- Absolutely. It's relatable.
So, do your fans come up
with theories for your books?
Do you get like, as well as names,
do they often send you ideas?
- Yes.
And, actually only two people know, like,
how the series ends, and
I have to keep it a secret
because I'm just so afraid
that people will know.
Like there's a love triangle in the book
and people are very fiercely
like Team Oro or Team Grim.
And so, people wanna know
who she ends up with.
- Yeah.
- So, I really, I have
to keep it a secret.
As much as I share on social media,
I have to keep some stuff secret
- [Kelly] Oh, absolutely.
- About the plot.
- My mother's the worst.
My mother, when you said the last page,
you find out on the last page.
My mother starts at the
last page. I'm not kidding!
- [Alex] Oh no.
- She has a giant spoiler.
She's like, "Oh, I just went to the end
to see what they're."
- And, I was like, "well
you missed the whole ride!"
It's like the whole, I was
like, "It drives me nuts."
But, she does that,
so I'm gonna tell her not
to start with the last page.
- Yeah.
- Do you have any advice
for, like, aspiring writers?
Because you came in the industry
in a very different way?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- I always say never give up.
I started writing books
when I was 12 years old.
This has been my dream
since I was a child.
And, it just, it didn't work.
I got hundreds of
rejections with every book.
And, this book, "Lightlark,"
was rejected by 16 publishers.
Almost every single single
publisher rejected it.
And, now it's been in New
York Times best seller
for over a straight year.
So, like, you just never know.
You gotta find someone who believes in it.
- You can't, it's because of the readers.
They did this.
So, as long as you put yourself out there,
you don't need to wait for
the gatekeepers to let you in.
You can truly, especially
now with social media
and self-publishing, you
can create your own destiny.
And so, I truly advise
anyone who's writing,
just put your work out there.
You never know what's gonna happen.
- Absolutely.
And, it's interesting you
mentioned Taylor earlier.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- She, well there's been a
lot of Taylors on the show.
(Alex laughs)
But, it's interesting,
'cause I remember hearing in
Nashville, she got turned down
by so many people, and then
finally got her opportunity.
And that's, what, she's
biggest star on the planet.
You just need one "yes."
- Yeah, you need one "yes."
And, you need a team that believes in it.
- Yes, exactly.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
And, I think it's a really
cool thing to tell people, too.
- Yeah.
- Because people can give
up or get disheartened.
- Yes.
- You know, pretty easily.
- Yeah.
- Especially creative people.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Well, alright, "Nightbane,"
the sequel to the bestselling
book, "Lightlark,"
is available now.
Y'all gotta go check it out.
Get a copy.